ah
I love you
hey I'm Chef Shire massoud and today in
the Tasty Kitchen we're gonna class it
up a bit for once we're making a spiced
Cod on Papillon which sounds fancy but
it's super easy it's just steaming fish
in a parchment packet let's get into it
our first step begins with seasoning up
this Cod so we're gonna make a spice
blend
starting with the star of the show are
McCormick Gourmet cayenne pepper that's
going to give us heat color and a little
bit of pungent flavor really really nice
so we start with that Cayenne next up a
little bit of garlic powder turmeric
goes in dill weed for that herbaceous
touch and last but not least lots of
smoky paprika we're going to add a
couple glugs of olive oil to kind of
make a paste that we can paint onto our
Cod
use the world's smallest whisk
whisk spices with the olive oil and you
can see it transform really quick into
this beautiful kind of paste
pastry brush
right onto the Cod and look at this
you're going to get that color
spice
and cod is the perfect fish for
something like this because it's mild
pretty neutral the fish becomes a
vehicle for these amazing spices we've
spiced our Cod and now it's a little
arts and crafts time we're gonna make
our parchment packet very easy here's
how it works get a large piece of
parchment paper fold it over like a book
and then I want you to imagine
a half heart shape so start at the
bottom
this is fun this is like kindergarten
all over again
it doesn't have to be perfect
when you unfold it
I love you here's how it works I take
our veg that I've julienned which is
just a fancy way of saying sliced really
thin I toss it in some olive oil and
salt notice no pepper the Cayenne is
giving us the heat in this dish put a
little bit of your Julian's veg
right in the center of your heart
and then take a piece of the Cod right
on top put some salt
a knob of cold butter on top and now
we're going to start to seal that
package so take one side fold it over
so you see I'm really making it tight
so that our parchment packet will
capture
all the steam that will release in the
oven I have a little opening here
now is the time for me to add a splash
of white wine and that wine and butter
is going to combine to make a sauce
while it Cooks in the oven
now at the end with that little pointy
part of the heart it's a good chance
for us to twist
really close it perfectly tuck it
underneath
we've got our perfect parchment packets
that's hard to say and they're ready to
cook 400 Degrees 10 to 12 minutes and
then we'll have a perfectly steamed fish
veg and a sauce will be created from
that buttery one
and there you have it a spiced Cod on
Papio you see fancy French food doesn't
have to be anything to be afraid of give
this recipe a try and enjoy
hmm spicy